today the solitary inventor
tinkering in his shop
has been overshadowed by task forces of
scientists public policy could itself
become the captive of a scientific
technological elite i fear that the
coven 19 pandemic show that president
eisenhower was right to worry that the
search for knowledge could become
captive of a scientific technological
elite and that the solitary inventor
tinkering in a shop could be
overshadowed by a cartel of experts with
backing from the state don't believe the
claim that the internet has corrupted
our public discourse with misinformation
experts don't have a monopoly on a
search for truth the internet has
improved the scientific process by
enabling anyone no matter their
expertise or credentials to speak up and
challenge prevailing wisdom take the
case of hydroxychloroquine in march 2020
the iconic classic french microbiologist
didier rayo announced that it had cured
36 covet patients enrolled in a clinical
trial it was a small study that wasn't
randomized or controlled but it drew
massive attention and i think it's going
to be very exciting i think it could be
the game changer and maybe not could an
inexpensive off-the-shelf drug really
bring a quick end to the pandemic
sweeping the globe the answer turned out
to be no and most radical scientific
ideas don't pan out but trial and error
is a necessary part of the process the
government added 63 million doses of
hydroxychloroquine to its national
stockpile of covet 19 treatments and
florida added a million doses exercising
their right to self-medicate some
coronavirus patients just started taking
the drug and then randomized controlled
trials showed that not only was there no
evidence that it helped covet patients
but it might be making matters worse we
need to listen to the health experts the
epidemiologists
we need to do what science dictates here
to save american lives
and if this president wants to be a
wartime president he needs to stop
vacillating listen to the experts or
simply get out of their way but the
lesson of the hydroxychloroquine
brouhaha is not that the scientific
establishment's uncredential challenges
should be silenced or cut out of the
conversation hydroxychloroquine didn't
prove to be kovit's miracle cure but
life-saving discoveries often come from
iconoclasts who threaten establishment
thinking consider some of the 19th
century breakthroughs that saved
millions of lives in 1847 ignorant
semmelweis begged his fellow physicians
at the vienna general hospital to wash
their hands before examining women in
labor samuel weiss was derided with the
same vitriol directed at the promoters
of hydroxyl chloroquine during the
pandemic the drug hydroxychloroquine and
hydroxychloroquine i do want to ask you
about hydroxychloroquine in 1854 the
public health establishment rebuffed the
contrarian dr jon snow for suggesting
that a london cholera epidemic was
originating from a water pump
contaminated with sewer water the
prevailing wisdom at the time was that
most disease was caused by invisible
gases rising from the ground if the
internet had existed in the 19th century
sema ice and snow could have gotten
their ideas out faster and it might not
have taken decades for the establishment
to accept they had been right all along
surgeons and physicians are vigorously
striving to erect a medical
establishment akin to our religious one
wrote the classical liberal philosopher
herbert spencer little do the public at
large know how actively professional
publications are agitating for
state-appointed overseers of the public
health spencer wrote that in 1851 but it
still applies today hydroxychlorquin
didn't work against covin but
experimenting with off-label use of
fda-approved drugs is a proven path to
medical innovation lithium treats
bipolar illness but was originally used
for gout and bladder stones the
horrifying side effects of thalidomide
on babies in utero when taken by
pregnant women to treat morning sickness
didn't dissuade innovators from
discovering that it could be an
effective treatment for leprosy and
multiple myeloma we need to welcome
heterodoxy even random people on the
internet with no medical credentials
might have groundbreaking ideas and
sometimes reacting to bad ideas could
lead to good ones it's true that medical
training can make it easier to detect
cherry picking of data and to really
understand what the evidence actually
says but i can tell you as a surgeon
with 40 years of experience working in
medicine experience and credentials can
also cause myopia making it harder to
see the value in radical new ideas covid
was so politicized that those who broke
with the priesthood were often attacked
as cranks accused of having blood on
their hands and kicked off social media
platforms for dangerous misinformation
once a theory is labeled conservative or
liberal it becomes difficult for
scientists to challenge it the harvard
science historian liv grieben noted in a
may 2021 essay some scientists are less
prone to question hypotheses for fear of
political and social pressures it was
pundits on twitter without any medical
credentials who saw the pandemic coming
at a time when some mainstream outlets
were dismissive and snide after the
pandemic started some dissenters from
conventional wisdom were banned from
youtube only to have their insights
later endorsed by the likes of the new
york times of the wall street journal
americans should be prepared that
they're going to have to hunker down
significantly more than we as a country
are doing an alarming new johns hopkins
university study shows that 2020
lockdowns only reduce covet 19 mortality
by 0.2
you know it's very interesting it shows
once again that vaccination is superior
to prior infections new data suggests
natural immunity from covid provided
better protection against the delta
variant compared to vaccination alone we
should continue to investigate
what went on in china until we find out
to the best of our ability exactly what
happened openness to unconventional
ideas has its limits we don't take flat
earthers seriously nor is it worth
paying attention to claims that covet 19
vaccines cause infertility implant
people with microchips or change their
dna they're not enough hours in a day to
fully address every hypothesis but the
best experts show tolerance respect and
openness to the opinions of outsiders
science is a profession it's not a
priesthood